[Music]
and what top bad news laptop laptop good
or not angry and wrapped up kappa ben
yosef submitted by bar top allah citizen
oh your city is growing by two people in
there now yeah it's not a metropolis
it's a bubble bar novelist everybody's
wrong the u.s. might extend the cabin
laptop and to all international flights
why are you using my wrong now allah if
they're scared we would honest
oh you can't bring a laptop onto the
airplane you know there's already a
laptop fan on the rig laptops are banned
from the cabin on flights from eight
countries which is Turkey Morocco Jordan
Egypt United Arab Emirates Qatar Saudi
Arabia and Kuwait I'm not going to any
of those countries so it's ok I'm ok not
having my family over in Turkey on our
way back from oh you gotta put your
laptop away I know
or maybe the Dubai here's the thing
though you my dear are thin enough to
wear you could use a laptop on a plane
my belly is too big oh gosh it's like
right here and right here so what I do
is get an iPad make a keyboard on lot
smaller do you think that's considered a
laptop in the eyes oddity 8.9 they're
saying that nothing bigger than a cell
phone is a load of [ __ ] that is iPad
is [ __ ] they get a big cell phone
there's a quick question then you can
bring it in your second luggage just not
your carry-on exactly okay so they're
not providing like video editors from
what do you Seban in the kabuna category
but a lot of people are saying that well
that could be just as dangerous is not
more because with so many laptop page
press speaks yes so so many laptops like
in the cargo hold the ion batteries in
there they could explode and it's like
one explodes and it could like trigger
the rest and there's no way of
containing a fire under there like the
the systems that they have for
containing fires and the cargo holes
aren't capable for an ion lithium ion
explosions you have to be chemical huh
I'm not sure exactly but I just know
that they can't contain the lithium ion
I know like knowledge they always ask if
you have lithium ion batteries before
you put it into a thing and I'm not sure
if they don't allow it or not they don't
they say you can't have it or yeah you
can't have it in the in the cabin yeah
so it's like what the [ __ ] you want me
to do then you want me to just like
[ __ ] naked from now on maybe we
should have a Korean spa rules just
[ __ ] butt ass naked don't bring
anything on the plane and that's it or
benefit without us isn't allowing it
either no so right now John Kelly which
is who is the Secretary of Homeland
Security I don't like this guy anymore
so he's saying that he met with European
officials and they discuss uh raising
the bar on these aviation security [ __ ]
that why the [ __ ] is he discussing our
family business with another family
because that family put in the state has
banned for those kinds of cares what the
Joneses are doing well it because
they're saying that right now the
terrorists are becoming obsessed with
taking down in US aircraft so now
they're taking security terrorists come
on pick something else man fog you've
already [ __ ] up my [ __ ] flight
plans
I got a [ __ ] of my work plans man you're
not worried about the safety animal
obviously I'm worried about the
convenience more than a safety such an
American inconvenience on a daily basis
add up to just one tragic event it's
pretty [ __ ] hilarious that they're
saying like that's what they're
obsessing about now so I just pictured
just Achmed and who love are just
sitting there we have to pray like I
have to do it I use the wireless
officers we haven't had a big event in
September 11 I know you know us but it's
really not way over - yeah like I just
thought we may get obsessed I think
that's the only thing that they want to
do what are the TSA scanners doing
they're scanning everyone's [ __ ] yeah so
what they're saying is the scanners that
they currently have they may not be able
to pick up a bomb that has been created
like inside of a laptop then get them
out of here so TSA can be much faster so
they're developing technology right now
to be able to detect that in the laptop
so they won't have the ink
you so so much no I mean when I got to
pull out my laptop into the tray
separately and they have to x-ray that
[ __ ] that should already be
enough yet if they still can't tell they
get those fools out of here they sup put
[ __ ] three dogs there no for the smell
that [ __ ] they'll smell the [ __ ] out of
the bomb maybe I opened up a laptop
rental team on the plane you passing out
to people
yep would you like to rent this out for
the remainder of the flight
there'll be $100 you can't even bring
the laptop by there clear through three
this would be kind of like water you
can't bring it inside but you could sell
it inside that's right yeah I'm starting
that [ __ ] up right now somebody give me
a million dollar what if this is the
airline's way of going another way to
make money in the air that's what I'm
thinking because they're making me pay
for Wi-Fi every time over-the-air do we
use it all inside I need it I absolutely
look for what because I bought a [ __ ]
and I'm too fat but they have a little
screens in the chair always oh not only
not always and having supplied a shorter
not always American Airlines
so you get some of those old planes it
is straight up this little box that's
like black and white in the middle of
this other row that you have to look at
it's [ __ ] terrible wait they don't
have Wi-Fi there either so you sit and
watch them I mean so imagine this you
forgot to bring books or anything it's a
three-hour flight
you ain't even tired cuz it's midday
right what you're going to do you can't
install games on your phone audiobook no
you're already on the plane so what are
you going to do
yeah you can't kill that has this thing
called an in-flight Go Go where you
could check out on your phone and you
could listen and watch TV all on your
phone not anakata
are you selling those for any other I
always use that [ __ ] gogo in-flight
entertainment yeah it's pretty dope
Southwest is pretty dope though because
Southwest even though they don't have
TVs in their [ __ ] they have what free
Wi-Fi for television [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
television and movies you can watch it
on your phone on your phone or your or
your iPad air stream is right through it
and then you can watch it right there
it's pretty [ __ ] cool turn the time
you have a conversation with the person
next to me [ __ ] I don't give a damn
about them I want to relax try to relax
when I get on a plane
as laptops and just infuriate you I just
think it's stupid because if you already
have like Joe said right you take the
laptop out they have a [ __ ] big-ass
machine that shows all kinds of [ __ ]
colors and it can see doing [ __ ] your
panties and [ __ ] why can't it tell if
there's a bomb in there and if it can't
tell that if there's a bomb in there and
get rid of that machine so people can
get to the slice way faster I get to me
it doesn't it's like what's the point
yeah while you have this lengthy process
that doesn't do anything because they're
not only screening for bomb just
screaming for all kinds of stuff like
what like a razor blade inside of the
laptop what's that gonna do hijack a
whole plane was like a pendulum animal
yeah what's the priority is a Prada to
not have exploding airplane or is a
priority to [ __ ] just to not have
weapons if you just [ __ ] put a ninja
on the plane and anyone that pulls a
knife I'll just get it happy yeah boom
you're done they do have that the air
marshals yeah so I'm like what it like
there's so many checks and there's so
many unnecessary checks and balances
because they're not even checking and
balance in each other that you just got
too many things to juggle we got to give
them a break we always have an Air
Marshal in cycle I think they do oh I
heard it was every flight but then
apparently it's not I I heard it was in
every single place I think some but they
should have like two of them like two or
three or four or five of them the whole
sign of their mush and dogs and just
give it a tsa it's just you on the plane
with the [ __ ] whole Navy SEAL just on
the plane with yeah yeah I don't know
I'm just kind of like conflicted because
I know the TSA and our security gets rid
of the threat before the threat happens
but man is it's just so hot
it's so inconvenient man come on man die
come on well yeah a lot of critics are
saying that officials should focus more
of their energy on suspicious
individuals rather than trying to like
create entire processes like what you're
very they're saying well you know why
it's because yet to be equal you have to
risk of social everything
that's the counter to that had found the
ground ball pay for that child that's
American Way right it's like we can't
just pick one group announced the things
they're just switching back and forth
all the time
Chloe eternities what the [ __ ] are the
dogs doing they're smelling [ __ ] right
they can smell bomb yeah fruit so BAM
get rid of the [ __ ] scanner thing
just get a lot of dogs get a bunch of
dogs or snowing all the [ __ ] and then
BAM we're done you can't smell a nice
there's still there so to build those
beagles they come around when I was
coming back from Taiwan there's this
lady and a beagle went up to her bats is
all happy sniffing and wagging his
[ __ ] pale I asked her do you have any
food in your leather she goes no opens
it up it's all food like rapido I've had
a terrible liar like it was just all
food and I think the problem is is the
good guy says they're the ones doing the
thinking and they're dumb bad guys are
always going to be smarter always right
so stop trying to out dinkum and just
make sure it easier and thing when
things will be fine there's so many
times where I accidentally let a knife I
mean I kept a nice time I carry on and
it's not until I land and I'm like oh
[ __ ] how the [ __ ] do they not even catch
this oh they're not catching [ __ ] in the
first place that's right I used to have
this thing in my wallet it was a credit
card that turned into a knife I had one
of those too yeah and I had it
throughout multiple slices made out of
plastic they don't know yeah I had no
idea
oh look I could've said somebody but one
time I had an actual knife like a
[ __ ] pocket knives and they didn't
even fall really that's terrible but
they're there to catch you when your
bottle is just a little bit I know haha
they threw away my [ __ ] face lotion
their shoes yeah I was so pissed
I was upset don't catch that but they
won't catch my [ __ ] gun that I
had up my [ __ ]
yes you did like and you can refuse
vodka you can just go to middle detect
yeah because you don't want to get
[ __ ] x-rayed all day like if you
travel all the time and you're just like
I don't like that [ __ ] men on x-ray
sensitive I totally can I get a body pad
instead so you actually have choices no
I didn't know that I want the body pad
but I have to ask them to do it softly
and slowly and do it while you look into
my eyes me man no we're cool and dim
delightful oh yeah please check my anal
cavity multiple times and I got buff it
in there please look into my
Isaac they always have me go through the
metal detector thing I never have to do
the body thing anymore
oh I don't have to do the body scan at
all right I'm TS a3 me to global enter
ray or you got an outfit okay it makes s
funny which they would have you go not
for the body scan because you can't you
guys go with them yeah they don't want
us to choose up yeah well they don't
even split Casey up either it's like how
many area in your group 3 ok I'll see
what never [ __ ] funny that I got
YouTube you're clearly not the father
you're Chinese actually that happened
you're like there was a there was a this
one time where are you smuggling this
Chinese I'm with her like what like why
are you separating us and then this
whole ordeal but yeah anything
she was listen did you guys make a scene
no no I would have made a [ __ ] scene
that [ __ ] [ __ ] is the father of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] and because of the racial
terms that little white - can law amount
of people do you want to contact me and
everybody else you see go ahead and
check the description box below and
follow our social medias is the grants
and Twitter's for more videos click up
there baby
[Music]